I want to focus in on the ordinary
American the ordinary British person
they're looking at an economy which is
lurching like you said from one end
extreme to the other right they're
looking at their savings being depleted
they're looking at prices going through
the roof what should they do in order to
weather the storm that is coming within
the next few months well there is a lot
they can do
and I'm going to give you an answer and
everyone rolls their eyes go that's
obvious the answer is diversification
everyone goes oh we know that you know
diversification but they know the term
but they actually don't know what
diversification is and I'll give you an
example I run into people all the time
they go well Jeff I'm fully Diversified
I have 50 stocks in 10 different sectors
telecommunications semiconductors
consumer non-durables metals and Mining
and I go you're not Diversified you may
have 50 stocks but you're in one asset
class called stocks or equities and
they're all going to go up together or
they're all going to go down together
and the more stressful the condition the
more reason you have to be concerned
about it the higher the correlation you
know at any given day some stocks go up
and stocks go down but when you dial the
stress meter up they all tend to move
together so that's I don't care about
your 50 stocks your 10 sectors that's
not Diversified so what does real
diversification look like have a sleeve
of equities if you want that's fine I
would say I look hard at oil Natural Gas
us natural resources agriculture again
kind of equities that have hard assets
behind them that will do well in
inflationary times or even in
recessionary times because you need all
those things uh no matter what
um then a slice of real estate you know
I wouldn't be in commercial real estate
but you know residential real estate
income producing real estate Farms Etc
that's good I have a big slug of cash
and people go well cash doesn't have an
EO well lately deals you can get uh two
three percent you know on like a CD but
even in a simple savings account
um you know it is quite low it's kind of
less than one percent but people don't
understand the value of cash in a couple
of respects number one in a deflationary
environment we're not there yet but we
could hit that if the recession gets bad
enough cash could be your best
performing asset it doesn't go up in
nominal terms but it goes up in real
terms if you have two percent deflation
your cash is worth two percent more in
terms of purchasing power but the but
the real value of cash is
optionality and this is not well
understood I shared an office with Myra
Shoals for six years so I see Options
under the pillow so to speak but uh
um if you're the one with cash when
things first of all it'll definitely
preserve well so if things are falling
all around you your cash will be what
it's worth unless you're in Silicon
Valley Bank it's a separate issue but um
although they got bailed out uh but so
it'll preserve wealth even if it's not a
high performer it'll do very well in
deflation but the real benefit is when
everything else is falling apart you're
the one who can go shopping so it's kind
of an at the money call-off Shield every
asset class in the world you know
everyone's selling everything in a panic
you can bite your time watch it go down
look for a bottom and then say okay now
I'll buy these things down 30 or 40 or
50 from where they were
some Alternatives I um uh you know I
have a number of investments in uh you
know private equity and Venture type
situations and yeah they're risky and
then not liquid but some of them will do
very well some of them have done well so
that's nice and then a slice of gold and
I recommend 10 uh because people you
know they put washing your mouth they go
Jim Baker says sell everything and buy
gold I've never said that not a good
strategy but 10 yeah but just holding on
there a second gym so you're saying to
diversify which is obviously you've said
gold you've said cash particularly in
the case of deflation and you're saying
stocks and options now there's a lot of
people who would look at things like
Bitcoin and would look at digital
currencies look at Jim's face
I know you're a big Bitcoin guy Jim
you're a huge fan huge fan of could you
please explain to people why
particularly this applies to younger men
who see these types of cryptocurrencies
as a shortcut to wealth and to generate
money for themselves right why this
might not be a good idea well
thank you
foreign